hey morale you look beautiful
Mariah Carey goes for a glamorous dinner
amid breakup rumors looking sexy in a
barely-there bra skin tight red leather
pants and sky-high heels
the singer stepped out with security and
a few pals for dinner at the famous Nobu
in Malibu on Thursday night also there
was one of her backup dancers Bryan
Tanaka a man mariah is rumoured to be
getting close with an eye witness tells
ET Tanaka left the restaurant about 10
minutes before the diva the two have
worked together for some time and Tanaka
was also at Carrie's Halloween party
just days earlier in an Instagram post
back in July he called her stunning and
a beautiful person he is toured with
Keri and danced in her Vegas show
he's also danced with Rihanna in the
past and he'll be seen on Mariah's
upcoming e docu-series et got exclusive
scoop on the situation between Mariah
and her fiance of about 10 months
billionaire James Packer we are told the
two had an argument last month while
vacationing in Greece and that they are
determining if they can stay together
interestingly Thursday night Mariah was
still wearing her engagement ring gonna
get the ring back
you